this is how we make fresh pickles every summer
one of my kids favourite snacks
first of all I'm gonna go out to the garden and pick some of my ripe
ready to go cucumbers
and I'm also gonna grab some fresh dill
now I'm gonna take this into the kitchen
and I'm gonna get some vinegar and water
and boil that on the stove and add some salt
I'm then gonna slice the cucumbers up into spears
this is the favourite way the kids like to eat them
and I'm gonna make sure they'll fit inside the jar
then I'm gonna pack them in tightly
just like how I would if I was going to can them
see I can pretty much get no more in here and then you're good
then I'm gonna pour that hot vinegar brine over the pickles
sorry cucumbers
they will be pickles
and then I'm gonna put those in the fridge and after about a week
they are pretty much pickled and ready to eat
they're absolutely delicious and the kids love them